[MUSIC PLAYING]
PRESENTER: Today's Massachusetts
Institute of Technology
is a world class center
for teaching and research.
Faculty, students,
and researchers
are united in their
goal to advance
the frontiers of knowledge and
solve contemporary real world
problems, following the vision
laid out for MIT 150 years ago.
But the place
itself has certainly
evolved and flourished
since those early days.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
It's hard to imagine how much
the scientific landscape has
changed from when founder
William Barton Rogers first
started thinking about a new
kind of Polytechnic Institute.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
DOUGLAS: William
Barton Rogers was
born at the beginning
of the 19th century.
And that marks the beginning
of an extraordinary time
in US history.
It's really the
transition that we're
going to witness over a century
from an agrarian rural country
into an urban and
industrial country.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SMITH: We're beginning to see
the emergence of large cities,
factories, railroads,
canals, all
the early instruments
of big-time industry
in the United States.
MINDELL: There's
surveying involved,
there's mechanical
engineering, there's geology,
there's all kinds of
civil engineering.
DOUGLAS: The sense
of possibility
of what this new technology
would mean for the country was
very much in Roger's mind.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
PRESENTER: William Barton
Rogers had a lifelong interest
in education.
And by 1835, he's a professor
at the University of Virginia.
He soon signs on to
lead a geological survey
for the state.
Though he loves the project,
he has a big problem
finding qualified workers.
DOUGLAS: Roger's
inability to hire workers
for his survey that combines
scientific knowledge
and the ability to use
technical apparatus
was a great problem to
his way of thinking.
He wasn't the only person
that needed an individual
with that skill.
The world was filled
with new industries,
and they all needed people
that combined smarts and skill.
PRESENTER: Eventually,
Rogers decides
to leave behind the frustrations
and political turmoil
he's encountered in
Virginia's slave society
and moved north to the
vibrant city of Boston.
SMITH: Boston was one of the
leading commercial centers
of the country.
And the area surrounding
Boston was, without question,
the most developed industrially
of any state in the Union.
ALLISON: There probably
was not an American city
that had more of a need
for engineers than Boston.
The city itself was
being transformed
by one of the
greatest engineering
projects of the 19th century,
the filling in of the Back Bay.
SMITH: And then you have
these reform movements,
temperance movements,
pacifist movements,
and of course, the famous
antislavery abolitionist
movement-- this was the place.
Boston was so radical
in its reform spirit.
ALLISON: The wealth
generated by all
of this industry, Bostonians
put into various philanthropic
enterprises and [? down ?]
schools, hospitals, libraries,
museums, various
institutions, which
benefit the broader community.
SMITH: Rogers writes
in his memoirs
how much he likes these
so-called enterprising spirit,
and even uses the
word, "knowledge
seeking spirit" of this area.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
PRESENTER: For
decades, Rogers had
been talking with
his brother, Henry,
about a new kind of
Polytechnic institution.
MINDELL: At the time,
the ideals of science
really focused on fundamental
principles, somewhat
disconnected from the
real problems of industry
and the people who
worked in industry.
SMITH: They began thinking
about how to incorporate science
into what they referred
to as the useful arts.
Today, we would call
that technology.
ALLISON: It's a
revolutionary idea
that someone will go to
school to get training
to become an architect, an
engineer, or a scientist.
These are typically
occupations that people
would learn by doing.
DOUGLAS: This was
experimental from the get-go.
Even the word technology
was new at that time.
KAISER: He wanted students who
had a grasp of human nature,
of basic sciences,
of mathematics far
beyond the requirements for
making this or that machine
work.
He wanted to train
students who would
be able to guide the nation
through industrialization,
not just build the widgets.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MINDELL: Different players
are coming together,
trying to bring a bunch of
different scientific and
practical institutions together.
And Rogers proves very skilled
at taking that set of people
and orienting their ideas
toward his proposal.
DOUGLAS: They knew it was
going to be in Boston,
and the land in Back Bay
was the place to put it.
So they were going to have
to convince the Massachusetts
state legislature
that not only was
the school worth establishing,
but that it was worth
designating a piece of land for.
MINDELL: The proposal was bought
to the state of Massachusetts.
And the first step is to
essentially incorporate it
as a state corporation.
And that's what we celebrate on
the founding day of April 10,
1861, when the governor
finally signs the MIT charter.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[EXPLOSIONS]
[WAR DRUMS]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
DOUGLAS: Just two days
after MIT's founding
on April 10 in 1861,
the first shots
are fired on Fort Sumter
in South Carolina.
And with the start
of the Civil War,
it meant that classes at MIT
could not start right away.
This proved fortuitous
for MIT because it
allowed them the opportunity
to raise additional funds
to acquire the land to start
construction to hire faculty.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALLISON: One can imagine
that when Rogers tried
to raise money, it's war
time and energies are
being devoted to other things.
Yet, on the other
hand, if we have
optimism about the
outcome of the war,
we can see the necessity
for young men and women
to become engineers
and scientists
to be able to solve
these other problems.
MINDELL: When the moral act is
passed in Washington in 1862,
it grants every state
some land that then they
can either use or sell to found
an agricultural or mechanical
institution.
DOUGLAS: Rogers
and his colleagues
won support from the
state legislature
that a portion of the funds
from the Land-Grant Act
would be dedicated
to this new school,
assuming that they could raise
the other funds successfully.
And then they had to
go out house by house,
factory to factory, and
convince people one at a time
to donate funds to
support this enterprise.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
PRESENTER: As the war
is ending in 1865,
the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology
holds its first
classes in rented space
in downtown Boston's
Mercantile Building,
while constructing its own
buildings near Copley Square.
Rogers' vision for a
new kind of education
with its emphasis
on hands on learning
made it crucial to establish
cutting edge laboratories.
KAISER: Rogers had a very
strong reaction against what
he considered rote learning.
And so from the beginning,
MIT was a great innovator
in getting laboratory work
right down to the earliest
levels of the curriculum.
Entry undergraduate
students would
be entitled to do a lot of
work in the laboratories
with their own hands, not
just seeing something else
demonstrate some effect.
DOUGLAS: Rogers
needed faculty who
were going to be
willing to invent
a new kind of curriculum,
that they were going
to have to cobble together
for the first time ever
laboratory exercises.
SMITH: He allowed his professors
to basically experiment
with it, tinker with it, adjusts
it, and build the program.
I think of pickering in physics,
for example, Professor Storer,
who was one of the
early chemists at MIT.
And both of them
become very famous.
And they're producing
textbooks to accompany
the lab-oriented
educational process.
MINDELL: If you look at the
curriculum offered in that very
first set of classes
at MIT in 1865,
it looks a lot like what
we call the GIRs today--
the General Institute
Requirements-- that still,
every freshman has to take--
mathematics, chemistry, physics.
Those were all required
at MIT from day one.
KAISER: There was an emphasis
on combining basic science
with applied things
in the field.
Students took field trips to
all kinds of working places,
where with the technological
world was being built.
And Barton Rogers
wanted all that right
in the curriculum for
his undergraduates,
right from the start.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
PRESENTER: As a young startup,
MIT had its share of hurdles--
ongoing money troubles,
takeover attempts
by neighboring Harvard.
But with every passing year with
every successful student who
went on to make his or
her mark in the world,
MIT's reputation grew
and the school's standing
became more and more secure.
By 1894, President
Francis Amasa Walker
was able to declare
in his annual report
that the battle of the
new education is won.
Proclaiming that the influence
of MIT and its innovative ways
are now recognized far and wide.
HASTINGS: In the early
years, the MIT way
of doing business with
a great deal of emphasis
on hands on and doing
things in reality
contrasted very substantially
with a more classically
oriented education.
With today, even for
those institutions,
which are more classically
oriented liberal arts,
they have moved
actually towards MIT.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
PRESENTER: By the
time operations
moved across the
Charles to the brand
new Cambridge campus in
1916, MIT's ongoing future
seemed assured.
Over the decades, the roadmap
Rogers laid out for his school
has proved flexible
enough to stay
true to his founding ideals,
while incorporating new fields
as they emerge.
SMITH: There have been
a lot of continuities
in the history of
MIT, especially
around the type of
curriculum that students
are required to follow.
There's surely a greater
range of choice today,
but the emphasis on combining
science with practice
is still an important
dimension of what is happening
around the Institute today.
HASTINGS: That idea
of mind and hands--
Mens et Manus-- that goes right
back to the beginnings of MIT
and its coincident with the
idea that the learning takes
place by doing, as
well as just by seeing.
DOUGLAS: MIT today shows
remarkable commitment
to the original vision
articulated by William Barton
Rogers of a place that solves
great problems, that educates
students who have
the capacity to be
independent in their thinking.
Those commitments are timeless
and stretch across 150 years.
[MUSIC PLAYING]